yet another officer-involved shooting of
an unarmed african-american man is
caught on video the police officer
suspended after video surfaced online
showing him repeatedly punching a man on
the street a surveillance camera
captured a deadly confrontation between
police and a twelve-year-old boy
carrying what turned out to be a fake
toy gun
[Music]
[Music]
you
I grew up in Brockton Massachusetts that
by Boston yeah it's like 20 25 minutes
away or so I feel like my only point of
reference for Massachusetts is Boston
yeah not Boston I might growing up there
I learned a lot it made me who I am
today but I was happy to get out of
there yeah I knew there was gonna be an
end date at some point yeah I'm actually
from Fort Smith Arkansas okay is a small
town right on the Oklahoma border I
actually have a very similar experience
to you and that it's a it's a lovely
place but I always knew that I would end
up elsewhere yeah yeah the expiration
dates a good way yeah it's like I love
going back to visit yeah so like growing
up did you have any particular view or
feeling about like cops or law
enforcement in general I definitely
didn't think that they were there for
our protection I feel like most
interactions that you have with them it
was always negative we had this one cop
in particular he would always be
stationed at the bus terminal and he
would just be staring at us and once you
look at him he would ask you looking at
and I feel he was oh and we were like 14
at the time so that was like the
majority like experience that I had with
them there were a couple we had that
were you know they were nice we have
this program called great it was gang
resistance education and training and
the cop who used to run that a cameraman
his name up top my head was so long ago
but he was he was legit like I liked him
he would always like check up on us make
sure we're doing everything right and
just he you felt like he actually cared
about you I feel like my perception of
law enforcement growing up was kind of
that I didn't have much of one because I
didn't really feel any sort of like fear
or have really much interaction with
cops I think as a kid there's like a
little bit of inherent like fear I guess
for lack of better word just because
it's more of like almost a reverence
thing not that like I think they're
super cool but just because they seem
like so important and they have guns and
stuff yeah
see cops and stuff on TV I didn't have
like the situation you had we're like
directly in my life there was a cop who
is routinely gonna be my friend which I
think would have made a big difference I
guess for me like I would have
trepidation or nervousness around cop
just because like it immediately like if
it was a cop there it's like legit but
like if I'm driving by or if I was if we
were like driving by somewhere and
there's like cops pulled over or
something it's more of just like oh
what's going on as opposed to any sort
of like real fear or like danger you
know just remember also from me just
growing up like when I was getting ready
to start driving my dad you saw his
telus like make sure you don't go to
move small towns if you ain't a hundred
percent legit he just touched you can't
ride with a hat on you can't ride with a
hood on cuz you're just gonna be
sticking out like a sore thumb and and
learning the hard way at one point when
I was about 16 but driving through some
small town in Massachusetts my brother
picked me up from work and he was
allowed to take the streets to get home
we get pulled over we had a headlight
out
yeah and the police officer comes up to
the window and I had my head down like
this and he asked me are you praying to
Allah or something I was like no I was
like the hell and he was like what are
you guys doing we just like we're just
driving home from work but uh he goes to
his car comes back says he smells weed
in the car pulls the side of the car
searches the whole car my brother had at
a beer in the back of in this trunk or
whatever it was unopened
but he was 18 I think at the time so
they arrested him for something and it
was something so stupid you got a right
had to call my dad to come bail him out
and just the whole time they were just
they were just dicks to us like treated
us like we were nothing like I've been
pulled over a fair amount when I was
younger like I've had you know
taillights out headlights out makes me
really bad about having expired tags and
like the times I've been pulled over
like especially I was younger like I was
nervous as hell
but it was but solely because like
gonna be so pissed it's like that's the
extent of a danger to me is like I've
never been pulled over for you like
headlights taillights tags whatever
speeding I've never once been asked to
step out of the vehicle
I've never once had my vehicle search
one time when I was like in I was in
college maybe you're like my late teens
I was like driving to my mom's place and
I got pulled over for like I think I was
just going to it was I got pulled over
for speeding and when I pull over in the
parking lot and I like didn't have my
current like I had my license but I
didn't have my current insurance card
and so I was like freaking out but the
cops in that case and they were both
like white we're like I was like can I
call my mom and have her bring it to me
oh yeah Wow me and my Porsche even gets
there they come back and like you're
feeling yeah like even that wasn't
necessary they just like let me go with
a warning I have gotten a couple tickets
but like in that case they were like now
like you can just we live in different
worlds you know and and I don't
unfortunately because I've been moving
to LA I'm only moving when I came to LA
in 2010 I was like oh la you know big
city super diverse I want no problems
this is literally the first time like
living out here where I would just get
pulled over just for the the police
asked me are you on probation or parole
have you ever been arrested what are you
doing here where are you going and asked
you over and over and over again and
there was one one situation probably I
was living on here three months and I
was out and in the city of Norwalk and I
had just started a new job which was
like I'll buy that way somebody gave me
a ride to the train station it was late
because I worked nights and I was a
hacker I'm waiting on trans as a gas
station when I walk over to a gas
station get something to drink
the sheriff's deputy they drive past me
they they did a u-turn it came back and
luckily I had saw them coming back so I
kind of prepared myself they hopped out
the car yeah did guns drawn I had this
like it was like a I worked at a
warehouse we had like these these like
sticks or whatever to get case from the
top rack and it was my first day trying
to have a locker yet
I gotta take home me and it looked like
a walking stick and they were like put
that on the ground put everything and I
was like dropped it on the ground put my
hands up and they were and then they had
me turn around slowly and I died and I
was like all right this is where it is
you know hopefully I make it out of this
one and then they once they like I turn
around they hosted a weapons and then
they just started asking me what are you
doing here where are you going why are
you here what are you doing were you
going on probation or parole have you
ever been arrested like over and over
and over they put me in the back seat
they're like took my socks my shoes off
searched everything and I was being
polite I don't you know I was like I'm
just going to walk I was like my first
day of work you know and one of the last
time that I got stopped just to be like
hey were you going
you know what are you doing here you're
on probation or parole and like no
reason to pull me I only give you a
reason and people always ask me oh well
aren't you you don't have to answer you
don't have to do this and I'm like at
the end of the day you do you know it's
because they're wet they want you to to
slip up you're not or just to act
suspicious or whatever if I get pulled
over now I still get real nervous but
the difference is it doesn't cross my
mind that I'm gonna be shot or like
harmed really I mean I have some
thoughts of like man these crooked cops
are gonna plan something that's like all
just from movies yeah yeah
my main concern when I get pulled over
is financial I'm just like man how much
is gonna cost
speeding yeah but it's like to me I like
I do get like even if I just pass a cop
I'm like my - were spent like is
everything good it's tags okay cool yeah
but like if I get pulled over I'm like I
do get nervous but it's just such a
different experience because like it's
my reasons for being nervous are
ultimately very minor and just like how
much is this gonna cost me what a hassle
this is something like privilege
problems to have like oh like officer
what are we doing here yeah I would just
say like this whole like tradition of
like the whole code of silence
you know you got to have each other's
back like at the end of the day like if
you know someone's you know just not a
good cop and not at you know like
they're not doing good police work speak
up and get them out of it and then once
y'all start standing up for the good
cops then we'll start to trust you a
little bit more and also to like take
time to learn about the community that
you're policing like if you're if you're
afraid of you know black folks or
Latinos or maybe don't be a cop in LA
and South Central LA or whatever you
know like go be a cop I don't know where
it's some other town fit like you know
deep in the valley or something like
that like it just take time to learn
about your community learn about what
people are going through and stuff and
and maybe why we don't trust you all you
think fear about what you just said like
the code it's like a big part of the
trust issue where it's like yeah like
you you five guys may all be great cops
but do we trust that like if you know
the sixth cop this is dirty yeah like
which is more important to you like
honoring the Brotherhood and the code
and stuff or doing what's right and I
feel like that trust has been broken a
lot during a lot of like what we've seen
in the last few years for those of us
who have had a more privileged
experience with this like the biggest
thing that you got to get out of your
head is that thing I mentioned earlier
where it's like well if you're not doing
anything wrong you don't have anything
to worry about and just that is not true
for an insanely large number of people
yeah and to not acknowledge that and to
not be constantly mindful of that does a
disservice to this entire topic yeah so
that's if I could stress that to other
people who have had similar experiences
to me is understand they're like yeah
like when I get pulled over I don't feel
like you know anybody's gonna shoot me
it's like great that's you yeah don't
discount other people's experiences
because they are very very real if
somebody if a friend is complaining
about something and maybe you not had
not gone through the same experience
with the police like you know you and I
had different experiences then don't
just automatically assume like I don't
know don't just shut them off maybe
listen you know
and hear them out
[Music]
[Music]
you